hey youtubers is Charlie in this week's
Teen Wolf is a superpower time Bob just
waiting to explode and even though a
bunch of the cast and crew were on
vacation they were live tweeting during
the episode a bunch of funny stuff from
behind the scenes also a quick reminder
comic-con is this week in the Teen Wolf
panel is on Thursday hello any new
people if you're just finding me for the
first time I do Teen Wolf videos every
week be sure to subscribe to get
everything
I'm doing a special Comic Con giveaway
I'll explain at the end of this video
and if you guys really want me to upload
the panel you can vote in the straw poll
there's a link in the description for
that so episode 5 had a few pretty
amazing WTF so I'm gonna start with my
top 5 and then do my review and then
I'll explain the Comic Con giveaway so
careful for spoilers from the episode if
you haven't seen it yet I'll wait just a
sec okay ready here we go number 5
Derrick is losing his powers they still
have not explained what it is the cake
took other than to say it's his true
essence the way I'm thinking about it in
my head is that she just took his wolf
mojo like the wolf part of his soul I
have a few theories about why that is
involving a lot of double-crossing and
the true identity of the benefactor
based on Derrick's progression his wolf
tank will probably be empty way before
the season finale like he'll be a normal
person sometime in the next four
episodes but what's he gonna do with
himself when he's not a wolf anymore
is he just gonna get a regular job he'll
be extra vulnerable to attacks I think
it's more likely that he would team up
with Chris argent and they tried to hunt
down supernatural creatures and help
them or he join the police force
it would be like Winchester brothers
Teen Wolf edition let me know if you
guys would actually watch that spinoff
if they made it but number four Lydia
and Malia decode the next part of the
list did anyone else feel like they've
totally reversed roles like Malia was
the one flipping out last week and Lydia
was the voice of reason and this week
Lydia completely lost her mind staring
at that creepy record player all weekend
and Malia was the normal one on top of
all that in each new episode it feels
like Malia is looking more and more just
like a totally normal teenage girl like
she's fixing her hair more and wearing
makeup
some of her reactions were still pretty
coyote adorable like almost resting her
head on Lydia's shoulder in the art
studio anyone else who's owned like a
really big dog will understand sometimes
like when you're sitting on the floor
they'll just come up behind you and put
their head on your shoulder it's really
funny the real WTF came later whenever
Lydia lost it all over Meredith but
pretty much everyone in the episode was
an AED waiting
explode so on to number three everyone
in the episode is an improvised
explosive device
that's what ie D stands for in case you
weren't sure in this episode they were
using it as a metaphor for Liam's
intermittent explosive disorder but when
you hear someone say ie D they're
usually referring to a dirty bomb that's
something you'd see in the military like
in the war in Afghanistan and Iraq like
a dirty bomb so the idea of a bomb going
off informed all the different plot
points as well as the character arcs and
of all the episodes so far this season I
feel like the writing on this one was
the best the more you can tie everything
back to that main theme in the episode
the stronger the story is like Lydia
blowing up in Meredith's face
Garrett blowing up on the lacrosse field
or Liam blowing up in everyone's face
the problem is is that not all those
IEDs can be cured with antipsychotic
meds
I love how Parrish kind of became the
Jeremy Renner character from Hurt Locker
fun fact that was actually the part that
got Jeremy Renner hired as Hawkeye on
the Avengers franchise parish's the
whole of the story but part of the I D
plot was disarming the people bombs
Parrish kind of disarmed Lydia but the
real callback was Scott and Stiles
throwing Liam in the shower that's
actually a nice callback to Scott
getting thrown in the shower when he
first started freaking out in season one
and that flashback where Peter threw
Derek in the shower after the basketball
game whenever he was a freshman I think
what we really learned is that none of
the male characters are allowed to
behave normally in the locker room like
it's a requirement that they freak out
but number two CSI Teen Wolf Tyler Posey
was talking about the CSI style scenes
that Stiles had saying that their editor
the person who edits Teen Wolf
used to edit for CSI and they have a
very particular way that they cut scenes
whenever characters are figuring out
Clues so that's why they called style
scenes CSI Teen Wolf just right off the
bat the scenes look beautiful from a
cinematography perspective but did you
notice all the red tape Stiles was using
it was a nice callback to his red
markers from season 3 and Malia's red
markers from this season at this point I
feel like red is the color of WTF on
Teen Wolf
like anytime something bad happens
someone gets murdered or they're trying
to figure out the Deadpool list red is
invoked for instance the Deadpool chart
full of red
Lydia's freaky record player red and
anytime Scott loses his [ __ ] on someone
his eyes glow alpha red so keep your
eyes peeled during the next episode any
time
think really crazy happens I'll bet
they'll be read somewhere in the frame
and my number one WTF moment parish is
on the Deadpool list I think we all kind
of suspected something was up with him
he's always been way too cool about
Lydia's supernatural status and all the
crazy Beacon Hill stuff that's been
happening just because he's on the list
doesn't guarantee that he's a werewolf
but what else do you think that he could
be the show widens the mythology every
year so it's totally possible he's
something that we have not seen yet here
is a thunder kitsune who can absorb
electricity and parish worked on bomb
disposal whenever he's in the military
so maybe his power has something to do
with absorbing explosions or maybe it's
something else related to his police
work if you had a supernatural ability
to look for clues for instance becoming
a deputy would be a really appropriate
career path he also said that he was
drawn to Beacon Hill's that's why he
came so it's possible that he's a
banshee just like Lydia and he was like
that WTF radar that she has I think the
show is shipping him with Lydia anyway
so I'll bet that he joins the pack
unofficially by the end of the season if
he survives which I hope he does and
just as a bonus moment whenever that
Calaveras showed up to talk to Chris
argent it wasn't one of my favorite
moments but it made me think of
something really interesting
they said that Brayden had gone missing
she was looking for Kate but what if
she's in on the Deadpool plot like what
if she's in league with the benefactor
or the benefactor herself for a while I
thought that Peter might be in on it or
at least the Kate part just to try and
use Derek's mojo to get his Alpha power
back but that seems a little bit
complicated I could see him sacrificing
all his money and letting all those
people die just to get alpha powers back
but usually the explanation is much more
simple the really interesting thing is
that the benefactor knew that Liam had
been turned into a werewolf and very few
people had been told about that and it
had to be someone who knew Aiden and
Alison I'm starting to think that it's
someone who's inside the pack or was
inside the pack technically that does
include Peter and Brayden but it could
also include Ethan and Isaac we haven't
seen them for a long time but if you
want a theory craft just keep it to
people close to the pack this is really
old generalization that most robberies
are inside jobs my craziest theory is
that it's Parrish like he has knowledge
of explosives like the one that disarmed
Kate and Derek in the vault but let me
know what your craziest theories are I
would not be surprised at all if Peter
or Parrish were working with Brayden or
Kate those four characters are
definitely on my
list overall the episode was a solid
b-plus I feel like there were two clear
parts of the story there was the pre
lacrosse and then lacrosse everything
before lacrosse was about finding that
ie D represented by Garrett and then
everything after lacrosse was waiting
for it to explode he could even make it
simpler than that it was like the whole
episode was about finding a bunch of
different bombs and disarming them
sometimes those bombs were people inside
the pack sometimes they were other
people like Garrett and violet and
sometimes there were actual bombs like
Parrish in the flashback so a lot of the
other really interesting things about
the episode were things happening
outside of it like Jeff Davis the
creator and Tyler Posey tweeting about
behind the scenes facts while it was
airing on TV Tyler said that his
favorite Derek Scott moment was when
Derek was congratulating him in the
locker room and Jeff Davis posted a
picture of them making Stiles opening
title sequence with all that red tape
this is what it looks like when they're
shooting it he's that not crazy all that
time for just a few seconds of footage
so the only other thing I'll say about
the episode is is they still have one
name to unlock that last part of the
Deadpool list it's probably someone in
the pack that has died that could be
Jackson or it could be any of the Dead
Hales it seems like it's all vendetta
killing in reaction to the deaths of
those key word characters like Allison
and Aiden like someone's trying to get
revenge for their deaths so in case you
didn't see it I'm doing a Teen Wolf
giveaway this week all you have to do to
participate is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video I'll be picking
a winner next week also be sure to let
me know if you want me to upload
highlights from the Teen Wolf Comic Con
panel so I'm gonna be doing a whole
bunch of other Comic Con videos too I'm
starting a playlist my next one is gonna
be a Marvel video be a preview for the
Marvel panel you can click here to watch
that and you can click here to get my
episode 4 video from last week thank you
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight high fives